assalam o shahe Dean Allen wasalamu
Cumberland dear viewers welcome to this
unique interview with Russian President
Vladimir Putin which we are recording in
Sochi with me here today on mr. Mohan
and khatib a reporter at Sky News Arabia
and salamu soffit a reporter RT Arabella
thank you very much for this unique
opportunity considering your upcoming
visit to Saudi Arabia Elmont occur a lot
of me it is my pleasure I think it's a
good tradition to meet with the
country's media before visiting it as
for the visit to Saudi Arabia we attach
great importance to it it is in a sense
a return visit after the visit by king
of Saudi Arabia custodian of the Two
Holy Mosques to Russia it was the first
historic visit we consider it historic
and it really is there is one more thing
that I believe is important to note in
Soviet times relations between Saudi
Arabia and the Soviet Union would a
rather low level in recent years the
quality of our relations has changed
dramatically we consider Saudi Arabia a
friendly nation I have very good
relations with both the king and the
crown prince we have been making good
headway practically in all fields I will
start with the economy there are still a
lot to be done but we have set a good
pace last year it was up to 15 percent
in the first six months of 2019 growth
was as high as 38 percent we're
considering some good joint projects our
direct investment fund and the public
investment fund of Saudi Arabia have
jointly established a ten billion dollar
platforms two billion dollars have
already been invested work is underway
on other projects and some promising and
interesting projects have already been
implemented we also consider it possible
to operate on the territory of Saudi
Arabia one of our companies exploring
the possibility of building a
petrochemical facility with investments
of more than 1 billion dollars it is see
ball holding Russia's largest company in
this sector we are fostering a
partnership in the trust based sensitive
area of military and defense cooperation
we have been negotiating for a long time
equally important are our joint efforts
to resolve the regional crises in this
regarde I would like to emphasize the
positive role Saudi Arabia has played in
resolving the Syrian crisis we are
working especially closely with Turkey
and Iran as you all know but I believe
that without Saudi Arabia's contribution
towards a Syrian settlement it would
have been impossible to achieve a
positive trend therefore I would like to
express our gratitude to both the king
and the crown prince for this
constructive approach I'm confident that
my visit will help to build up the
momentum both in developing bilateral
relations and enhancing cooperation in
international organization mr. president
thank you very much once again for
giving us the opportunity to record this
interview your visit to the Middle East
will possibly have an impact on the
United Arab Emirates as well what do you
think about strategic cooperation
between Russia and the USA II and how
would this cooperation evolve can this
cooperation play a certain role in
strengthening collective security
considering the Russian initiative to
establish a collective security
architecture in the Gulf region
especially in the area of the Strait of
Hormuz you've just mentioned the
strategic nature of our cooperation
indeed we signed a strategic partnership
memorandum last year and we see the
United Arab Emirates as one of our very
close and promising partners the finding
of this document was not a coincidence
it demonstrated the quality and nature
of relations between the United Arab
Emirates and the Russian Federation I
have to say that as is the case with
Saudi Arabia our partnership is
vigorously developing in all areas of
all the Gulf countries we have the
highest level of trade 1.7 billion
dollars but of course this is not enough
we are well aware of that so currently
we are working with the UAE sovereign
fund the joint platform is worth
approximately seven billion dollars two
billion dollars have already been
invested work is underway on other
projects and of course it is safe to say
that the United Arab Emirates greatly
contribute to resolving regional crises
and play a stabilizing role in the
region it is no a great secret that we
made
regular contacts with the leadership of
the United Arab Emirates there is even
an established tradition a practice to
compare notes regarding different topics
in my opinion we are doing it for the
benefit of both parties and the region
as a whole
mr. president in the more than 10 years
of your presidency some harsh dramatic
developments have taken place in the
Middle East and the statehood of several
countries has been undermined namely
Iraq and Libya we see that this could be
the fate of other states as well we see
what happened in the Syrian Arab
Republic what catastrophic events took
place there now many members of the Arab
public think that Russia can really
bolsters role in the region you surely
know that our network air T Arabic
covers Russia's foreign policy as well
many our viewers have been asking
straightforwardly why as Russia taken
such a harsh stance in the case of Syria
but the position regarding Libyan rock
was perhaps not as hard a place could
you decide with your group first of all
during the crises in Iraq and Libya I
was not in office but this is not the
main research the thing is that as is
commonly known in the case of Iraq the
United States circumvented the United
Nations Security Council the US has no
mandate to use force against Iraq
actually I was president at that moments
anyway Russia did not support the
invasion Russia France and Germany did
not support the u.s. plans regarding
Iraq what is more we warned about the
potential adverse implications and
that's exactly what happened
the initial euphoria of military victory
soon gave way to despondency in
pessimism about the consequences of the
victory because all Iraqi government
institutions were destroyed but no new
institutions were established at least
in the beginning when you put on the
country the radical forces got a boost
and terrorist groups became stronger
many former officers of Saddam Hussein's
army and security service agents
resurfaced and joined the ranks of what
later evolved into Isis so those who led
and supported this campaign had not
considered the ramifications we do
expect that there will be some positive
developments in Iraq and despite some
internal problems the country will
continue to move forward although there
are still a lot of problems to deal with
we're perfectly aware of that as for
Libya the chaos wrought by
military operations still prevails but
in this case our Western partners played
a trick on us Russia voted for the
corresponding Security Council
resolution after all what does this
resolution say if you read it carefully
the resolution prohibited Gaddafi to use
aviation against the rebels but there
was nothing about allowing any air
strikes on Libyan territory so that was
actually what happened so basically what
happened there was done circumventing
the UN Security Council and we were all
aware of what happened next they're
still chaos and confusion a flow of
migrants went through Libya to Europe
Gaddafi had always warned about that he
said that he stopped African migrants
from going to Europe as soon as this
wall was gone they started pouring into
Europe and now they have what they were
warned about but that is probably not
even the main issue most importantly it
is destabilizing the entire Middle East
region that's the Syria we came to Syria
to support the legitimate government and
I would like to emphasize the word
legitimate it does not mean that they do
not have internal problems I'm ready to
talk about it in detail later it does
not mean that the current leadership is
not responsible for what is going on
there they are but it does not mean that
we were to allow terrorist organizations
to capture Syria and to establish a
terrorist pseudo state there we could
not allow militants to move to former
Soviet republics we do not have hard
borders or a visa regime with them we
could not allow militants to infiltrate
Russia from there we already had such an
experience and we know what this might
lead to we still remember what happened
in Russia's North Caucasus region not
that long ago this is why we made a
decision to support the legitimate
government we've not just provided
assistance to the legitimate government
we proceed from the premise that
internal political contradictions must
be and can be resolved by political
methods only that is why we were so
adamant I am glad to see it happening
now as part of the political process as
a result of the establishment of the
so-called constitutional committee this
idea was conceived right here in Sochi
at the Syrian National Dialogue Congress
that brought together various political
forces including the opposition and the
government and here Syrians agreed among
themselves to set up a constitutional
committee that would work on changing
the Syrian Constitution
or drafting a new one we've trodden a
hard arduous and long path to form this
committee now it's finally been formed
on behalf of the government on behalf of
President asset and on behalf of the
opposition I expect that in the coming
days it will take its first steps in
Geneva under the auspices of the US mr.
president you spoke earlier about the
relations between Saudi Arabia and
Russia as you know it is a strategic
partner of the Russian Federation in
terms of energy security you must be
aware of the to missile and bomb strikes
on the oil refinery and of the most
recent developments there has been talk
in Saudi Arabia about Iran playing a
destabilizing role in the region you
said that evidence had to be found to
prove that Iran was really behind that
what is the official position of the
Russian Federation regarding this
incident our official position is as
follows we condemn any such actions end
of story
this is the official position we said
this at the very beginning and I've
recently reiterated it at the Russian
energy week forum in Moscow there should
be no room for doubt here such actions
never yield any results for anyone
including those who plot and execute
them why if someone may have wanted to
deal a blow to the oil market they
failed there were indeed some
fluctuations in prices but I do not
think it was anything too serious even
though the initial response was quite
strong the prices that went back to
normal in the very first week because
the fundamental factors said that the
market depends on will never allow the
prices to either skyrocket or take a
nosedive
secondly we and I personally maintain
close contacts with the leadership of
Saudi Arabia including Crown Prince we
discussed the incident and I told him
that I thought it necessary to collect
evidence to find the perpetrators behind
that incident Mohammed bin Salman agreed
with me in principle and asked me a
question
could Russia take part in the
investigation I said yes we are ready to
share anything that might be necessary
everything we have for a thorough
investigation our position remains
unchanged it is counterproductive to put
the blame on someone before finding out
who was behind the incident Bulacan
Bahamut Royce mr. president can Russia
give any assurances that if it is
revealed that Iran masterminded the
attack that Russia will join other
countries in condemning it I have just
said it and I will repeat regardless of
who stood behind the incident we condemn
any such actions this is exactly what I
said before and I really meant it there
is no other way to interpret this let us
now put these attacks on the old
facilities aside I think you are well
aware of the tension that has mounted in
the region and you must have been
analyzing this situation yourself there
is concern about Iran's role in not only
these recent attacks but also in what is
happening in other countries in Lebanon
Yemen Iraq Syria and some others do you
think Russia has the same concerns about
Iran's activities which we think are
having a destabilizing effect can Russia
do anything to change Iran's behavior on
us as I said we have an unprecedented
level of partnership I would even say
friendly relations with Saudi Arabia and
the United Arab Emirates but Russia will
never be friends with one country
against another we build bilateral
relations that rely on positive trends
generated by our contacts we do not
build alliances against anyone this is
my first point the second day you and
your audience understand I believe that
Russia and Iran are neighbours this is a
factor we always bear in mind thirdly
Iran is a major regional power an
ancient country with a rich cultural
legacy if we want to build good
relations with the country and I believe
every country in the region would want
to have good relations with each other
no one seeks a standoff or perish the
thoughts any conflict no one does
I know that there is no one looking for
a showdown and that's is true for both
Saudi Arabia and the UAE if we want to
set a positive agenda we need to
acknowledge that our partners have their
own legitimate interests I'm not
weighing in on what is legitimate and
what is not
I just want to underscore that it is
only natural that a big country like
Iran which has existed on its territory
for thousands of years and has its own
interests Persians and Iranians have
lived here for centuries and we should
respect those interests of course it is
debatable what is legitimate and what is
not which interests are legitimate and
which cross the line and whether you
need to have dialogue to understand each
other to puzzle out all the nuances
intricacies and issues without dialogue
you cannot solve any problem that is why
I think I can share the concerns of the
UAE and Saudi Arabia but in the case of
bilateral issues it is up to them to
resolve them as for Russia we will do
everything in our power to create the
right conditions for positive change
Russia has cordial relations with Iran
and is on very good terms with our Arab
friends back in the Soviet times we did
not have any particular deep relations
with Saudi Arabia but we were truly
close with almost all the Arab countries
the Soviet Union was on very good terms
with the entire Arab world today we're
back to the same level of partnership
therefore if we put to good use the
cordial relations that we have with Iran
the Arab world Saudi Arabia and the UAE
I think we can come up with something it
would be of interest so everyone
previously I mentioned the positive role
that we play in Syria it's true that we
turkey Iran and Russia work hard
shoulder-to-shoulder to achieve positive
results however it would have been
impossible without support from Saudi
Arabia and we understand that and of
course without assistance from the UAE
as well it means that despite acute
contradictions there's still something
that brings us together towards a common
goal
you just need to find such a goal and
then apply concerted efforts to reach it
that can create the right setting for
the normalization of relations between
the countries in the region
staying with Iran some say that the p5
plus one talks should be resumed
moreover the common opinion is that the
agreement should also cover the
ballistic missile program what is
Russia's position here regarding the
call to revive that frame
and possibly modify the agreement
extending it to some other issues and
that it will feel about however do a
little de Medici
there is the jcpoa or the Iran nuclear
deal which specifies certain limits and
commitments for Iran and Iran has
accepted them let us be frank here
otherwise the conversation will be too
dull the countries of the region do have
some contradictions and you have just
mentioned them there is disagreement
between Iran and Israel Iran and the
u.s. I believe that attempts must be
made to settle those disagreements seek
a way out of the complicated situations
that we observe today however if we
agree that there are contradictions
between regional powers and Iran then
who can take up the role of an
arbitrator and decide whether Iran
complies with the jcpoa or not first and
foremost an arbitrator should be
impartial right second an arbitrator
should be professional third there
should be someone respected by the
international community we have such an
arbitrator with the IAEA the
International Atomic Energy Agency and
the IAEA has publicly without any
hesitation said that Iran fully complies
with all its obligations what we're
seeing is not quite productive not to
mention that it is just unfair to blame
Iran for failing to deliver on some
commitments it is counterproductive
because when a person or a country is
treated so unfairly they start acting in
a way different manner not the way
existing agreements require when one
party does not abide by its obligations
why would the other still honor them
nevertheless I believe that Iran should
follow both the letter and spirit of the
agreement but this is a different
question as for the missile program
I suppose the issue can and should be
part of the discussion too in Russia
there is a saying and I think Muslims
would understand the meaning as well you
should know the difference between God's
gift and Friday these are two different
matters the missile program is one thing
and the nuclear program is something
different it is not implied that the
missile program should not be part of
the conversation especially since it
raises certain concerns there is a place
for discussion but let us not mix apples
and oranges here otherwise all the
progress has been made could be totally
lost therefore I think that such a
discussion
takes place but it should not cancel out
all the achievements on the principle
track that is putting a cap on Iran's
nuclear activities is my own fear I
would like to ask you a question on the
matter namely security in the Gulf
region it has truly seen a lot of
developments recently there have been
dramatic incidents attention of tankers
a missile and bomb attack on the Syrian
army Co refinery in the aggression that
continues around Yemen the recent
attacks on Saudi Aramco oil facilities
strongly affected sentiment in the
region as we can see in your view what
will be the impact of all these high
profile incidents on cooperation under
OPEC agreements so far regional power
has not made any specific statements
regarding Russia's proposal for a
collective security strategy in the
region how do you plan to promote that
collective security initiative do you
think it will ever see the light of day
your questions seem to be linked but
still deal with separate issues our
cooperation with OPEC plus is one thing
while regional security and stability
and our proposals is a different one
first if anyone thinks that seizing tank
is an attacking oil infrastructure can
in any way affect cooperation between
Russia and our Arab friends Saudi Arabia
and the UAE that they can undermine or
break down our cooperation with OPEC
plus then they are profoundly wrong on
the contrary we will Forge ever closer
ties because our main goal is to
stabilize global energy markets
technically we need to cut global
reserves to some sensible level so that
these reserves do not affect prices
we've made some good strides and
whatever we've managed to achieve has
served not only oil producers but also
consumers neither producers nor
consumers want high prices rather we all
want stability in the global market let
me be straight with you all that's been
done under the leadership of Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman overall those
were his initiatives and we just backed
them now we see that we did the right
thing we need to respond to any attempt
to destabilize the market Russia will
certainly continue working with Saudi
Arabia and other partners and friends in
the Arab world to counter any attempts
to wreak havoc in the market now let us
turn to Russia's initiative to stabilize
the situation in the Gulf region we put
that initiative forward some time ago we
proposed to establish some sort of
organization it would bring
together the countries of the region as
well as several other stakeholders the
US and the EU to name just a few
this organization would serve as a
platform to discuss crises and all kinds
of pressing problems some have already
voiced their support others say it's too
early to launch such an initiative and
the reason for that by the way is these
serious contradictions between regional
powers from my point of view these deep
contradictions call for such a platform
so that countries could at least sit at
the negotiating table as you may be
aware sometimes it's not the
negotiations that matter but a handshake
a handshake can mean a lot it is far
from a follow-up question if I may can
we rely on Russia's efforts as a
mediator between the Islamic Republic in
Saudi Arabia or on a larger scale in
order to help relieve the tension in the
Gulf region the role of mediator is not
a rewarding one I believe that our
partners in Iran and Saudi Arabia do not
need any mediation since we maintain
very friendly relations with all the
countries in the region including Iran
and the Arab states such as Saudi Arabia
and the UAE we could certainly help
relay some messages between the parties
so they could hear each other's position
but since I personally know the leaders
of these countries and perfectly sure
that they have no need for any advice or
mediation what you can do is maintain a
friendly conversation with them and
present some ideas from a friends
perspective and convinced that as highly
intelligent people they listen and
analyze everything they hear from this
point of view yes we could play a
positive role in the process to some
extent mr. president if you allow me I
would like to ask the straightforward
question you have just said that all
allegations against Iran in regard to
these strikes are premature you recently
met with President rouhani did he
reassures in any way that Iran had
nothing to do whatsoever with these
strikes and was not involved in this in
any way yes that is exactly what he said
he said that Iran had nothing to do with
this we met on the sidelines of an
international summit
it was the summit of the Eurasian
Economic Union or an organization we
created with a number of
Soviet states a few months ago the
Eurasian Economic Union and Iran signed
an interim agreement on a free trade
area we have a free trade area agreement
with Singapore and Vietnam and we're
also working on one with Israel and
Egypt the Eurasian Economic Union
enjoyed a successful cooperation with
many states across the globe Iran is
about to join this process and we
discussed these prospects just recently
on the sidelines of the summit in
Yerevan in Armenia one more question if
I may mr. president
Russia certain plays a role in the Gulf
region and your intelligence agencies
have a huge capacity it is hard to
believe that Russia does not know what
really happened to those oil facilities
is it possible this opinion believe it
or not we do not know I ask the heads of
the Foreign Intelligence Service and the
Ministry of Defense the very next day we
do not know I will refrain from any
further comments as to who should know
in order not to hurt anyone's feelings
but I can say that we do not have any
definitive information regarding the
incident can we move to Syria now mr.
president you recently announced a
suspension of large-scale combat
operations in Syria and everyone is now
hopeful that political settlement works
you spoke about it at the Val Dai forum
here in Russia you said that Syria could
become a good example of how such
conflicts must be approached and settled
do you think that we can talk about a
political settlement while other
countries forces are still deployed in
Syria I mean the United States Russia
Turkey and Iran is there hope to achieve
stability in Syria amid these
destabilizing factors there is always
hope do not ever give it up I can only
agree with you that all that the forces
deployed illegitimately inside any
sovereign state in this
Syria must leave this is true for
everyone if Syria's new legitimate
government chooses to say that they have
no more need for Russia's military
presence this will be just as true for
Russia right now we're discussing this
openly with all our partners including
Iran in Turkey we spoke about it with
our American partners many times and I
will be open with you as I have been
with my counterparts Syria must be free
from other states military presence and
the territorial integrity the Syrian
Arab Republic must be completely
restored do you have a vision for
Syria's political future and what role
does Russia play in it it is a difficult
question and it is a question that only
Syrians can answer I hope that they do
so not by taking up arms and fighting a
war against their own people but through
negotiations in this case as I said in
Geneva the very first step along this
path is to work on the country's
constitution whether by amending the
existing Constitution or drafting a new
one in either case it must protect the
interests of all the ethnic and
religious groups people need to know
that they live in their own country and
then it protects them by law it must be
equally true for Sunnis and Shia for
other whites and Christians because
Syria has always been a state with many
religions and it could pride itself on
this any sane people could have started
a deranged purging campaign killing
other people as these terrorists in
Syria again it will not be easy it will
be a difficult process but I believe it
can work do you know why I feel positive
about it people are returning home we're
talking thousands of people returning
from abroad and from other Syrian
provinces they are coming home this is a
sure sign of the trust they have in the
situation we have today they trust the
government and its guarantees and they
trust the guarantor States I'm happy to
say that Syrians welcome and trust
Russian troops and Russia's military
police the military police units
deployed there are doing a good job
mostly Muslims from the North Caucasus
and the local residents trust them and
feel free to ask them for help and
protection sirs I've reports of such
cases I'm happy to say all this but in
order to have long term peace if people
need to find a way to
settle things between themselves the
worst piece is always better than the
best let us leave the Middle East and
the Gulf region for now you always say
that rush American relations need to
improve because otherwise if there is a
fault in these relations this may change
the situation for the worse globally
today as you look at the Trump
administration as you read Donald
Trump's tweets do you see any hope for
any steps to improve relations between
the two countries
you surely follow the u.s. president's
statements don't you I must say that I
do not have any Twitter account or
anything so I do not follow anyone there
of course I get reports from my staff
from time to time the opinion of the
President of the United States always
matters it is always very important for
many parties and for the whole world but
I do not follow him personally as an let
us assume president Trump is reelected
next year do you think he could be more
promising president he might have more
courage to de-escalate tension between
Washington and Moscow and will Russia be
willing to resume dialogue say hakuna
cotton for Russia today don't you well
it is because of people like you that
Russia we accused of meddling in the
election because you just said now that
Trump could be reelected they will say
gotcha
this is Russia interfering but the
election campaign jokes aside we all
know what President Trump says about
russian-american relations and how he
talks about them we know that during his
previous campaign he called for
relations to get back to normal but
unfortunately nothing has been done but
we do not hold it against anyone because
we can all see what is going on in the
American domestic political scene these
days the domestic political agenda
prevents the incumbent president from
embarking on a drastic improvement of
relations between our countries in any
case we will work with any
administration to the extent it's
willing to work with us however we
cannot help but feel concern over
overall global security and strategic
balance this is obvious in 2002 and
present Trump has nothing to do with in
the United States withdrew from the ABM
Treaty which I would like to reiterate
was the cornerstone in the entire global
strategic security system because it
imposed limits on the missile defense
systems of our current
do you see the point the point was to
make it clear that neither party can
ever win a nuclear war should it happen
this was the whole point the United
States withdrew for the treaty in order
to secure some serious strategic
advantage for themselves thinking that
they might shield themselves from a
threat unlike Russia it would leave
Russia in a very vulnerable position
while the US will be protected by an ABM
system back then I told our US
counterparts that there is no way of
knowing how well such a system would
work and so we will not waste tens of
billions on it but strategic balance
must be maintained which means that we
will develop offensive weapons that will
defeat any ABM system and we have
developed them and everyone knows it by
now the ABM systems are designed to
intercept ballistic missiles ie missiles
that follow ballistic trajectory whereas
what we did was we enhanced improved
ballistic missiles significantly and
developed a new weapon that has no
rivals in the world we have hypersonic
missiles that follow a low trajectory
rather than a ballistic one no one has
hypersonic missiles today except us of
course the world's leading powers will
one day develop them sooner or later
but we will be able to come up with
something new by that time I know what
projects are scientists researchers
designers and engineers are working on
right now unfortunately this has led to
an arms race of sorts but that's is what
has happened it is a fact sadly this is
true now recently the u.s. also withdrew
from the intermediate-range nuclear
forces INF treaty I think it was a
mistake to and that they could have gone
a different path I do understand the
u.s. concerns while other countries are
free to enhance their defenses Russia
and the US have tied their own hands
with this treaty I still believe it is
not worth ruining the deal I believe
there were other ways out of the
situation the New START treaty is
actually the only treaty that we have to
prevent us from falling back into a
full-scale arms race it serves to
further reduce and limit strategic
offensive arms that is to limit the
entire range of strategic weapons the
entire strategic triad land sea and air
based combat intercontinental ballistic
missile launches this treaty expires in
2021 to make sure it's extended we need
to be working on it right now
we've already submitted our proposals
they are on the table of the US
administration there has been no answer
so far our understanding is that they've
not made up their minds yet as to
whether they need to extend the treaty
or not but if this treaty is not
extended the world will have no means of
limiting the number of offensive weapons
and this is bad news the situation will
change globally it will become more
precarious and the world will be less
safe in a much less predictable place
than today let us get back to
disarmament mr. president do you think
that a new arms race could plunge us
back into another Cold War I wish it
does not happen in any case Russia will
be the least affected party because as I
said we already have the next generation
of weapons and these are unprecedented
with unmatched capabilities in that
sense we've done our homework we do not
need to rush now and can calmly think of
what could be done next military
spending also plays a role here it may
or may not come as a surprise to you but
Russia ranks seventh in terms of defense
spending Saudi Arabia's third US
military spending totals 716 billion if
I'm not mistaken and next year they
asked for 750 billion
next comes China with around 177 billion
followed by Saudi Arabia 59 billion
right training behind of the UK France
Japan with 48 point 1 billion based on
the data I have and Russia is only
seventh with 48 billion however we have
unmatched military capabilities what has
made it possible it comes as a result of
focus research on priority areas and the
credit here goes to our specialists
their ability to identify those areas
immobilize resources it has been made
possible thanks to research institutions
production know how fundamental
knowledge and competences therefore an
arms race is a bad thing and it will not
be good for the whole world however we
will not be dragged into exorbitant
budget spending gauged despite this NATO
continues to press forward do you feel
that the Alliance is marched towards
Russia's borders is a threat how will
you respond to it we do feel it
certainly we've always felt it and
voiced our concerns
we were told don't be afraid you're not
the time
and there is nothing to fear NATO is
changing it is no longer a military blog
it does not have belligerent intentions
and stuff like that in the meantime the
North Atlantic Treaty remains in place
in particular article 5 if I'm not wrong
that guarantees military support to
other members etc it is a military bloc
and its infrastructure is moving closer
to our borders we're not happy about it
there is another trick I think it's
clear to everyone that NATO is just a
u.s. foreign policy tool Europe is aware
of it take the French president I do not
need to make anything up another trick
is that once countries join NATO they
have no say over the arms that are
installed on their territory this was
the case in Romania with missile defense
Poland will soon get it - it will be
really close to our border it is
certainly a threat to us we see it as an
attempt to neutralize our strategic
nuclear capabilities however it is clear
their efforts are doomed to failure
I believe experts now see this as well
now that we have the cutting-edge
systems that I mentioned earlier these
moves are no longer a threat to us I do
not want to say what we really think
about it still there's nothing positive
about it so yes we do see this as
destructive activities that escalate
tension there is nothing good about it
mr. president
another issue that used to be in the
limelight I'm referring to the
palestinian-israeli settlement like the
Soviet Union Russia has played an
important role in resolving the issue
take the Madrid conference for instance
however in recent years Russia has not
been very active on that track while the
u.s. is trumpeting a so-called deal of
the century in the meantime the Israeli
government is going ahead with its
arbitrary
authoritarian policy what is Russia's
role in resolving the issues that are so
fundamental to the Middle East this does
not depend on us or our actions is up to
all the stakeholders whether they want
to see someone in this process or not
incidentally we have very good relations
with Israel as well almost 1.5 million
Israelis come from the former Soviet
Union Israel is almost a
russian-speaking country the Russian
language is often heard and shops
everywhere we do care about
what is happening in Israel however we
have a principal position on the
israeli-palestinian settlement we're
fully committed to all the UN decisions
and believe that they must be executed
now on the deal of the century
we will support any deal that will bring
about peace but we need to know what it
is about the US has been pretty vague
about the details of the deal
Washington has kept in the dark the
global and domestic public the Middle
East and Palestine we believe is
important to ensure a two-state solution
and establish the state of Palestine we
suggested hosting direct talks in Moscow
between the Israeli prime minister and
the head of the Palestinian Authority
but the meeting never took place
unfortunately we've been doing what we
can we have held several meetings
between different Palestinian groups
restoring Palestinian unity would be a
major contribution to the process
speaking with different voices
undermines the United Palestinian stance
but we are working on it it does not
mean that we have to quit the process
altogether and are no longer interested
in it we're deeply committed primarily
because we believe that the
israeli-palestinian conflict is key to
resolving many other regional issues
unless it is resolved it will continue
to feed radicalism and terrorism among
other things and people feel they have
no legal ways to uphold their rights
they take up arms in this sense I feel
the Israelis are also interested in a
long-term ultimate solution not just the
Palestinians mr. president we are
running out of time we do not want to
steal time from our colleagues you have
made fairly positive comments about
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
you seem to have close and good ties
with him do you count on the positive
role that he can play in fostering the
Russian Saudi relationship and in the
Middle East agenda in general document
guru that is exactly his role today and
he's been quite successful indeed we
have very good personal ties he's been
behind many of our initiatives and these
projects are being put into practice as
I said he came up with opec plus he
endorsed the joint platforms of our
investment funds two billion worth of
investment has been made by now he
raised the need for broader defence
cooperation and we have a good plan of
joint activities in that area
this is already happening hopefully our
collaboration will continue to expand
going forward as for Saudi Arabia's role
in the region it's definitely one of the
key countries there it does have an
impact based on its capabilities and its
position in the energy market
Saudi Arabia can be safely called a
global player since it has an impact on
the world energy market on world energy
in general this is why cooperation with
Saudi Arabia it's king and crown prince
bin Salman is very important and we will
develop our relations going forward
before we came here we did a poll an RTI
robux website we asked a simple question
if he had a chance to meet the Russian
president what would you ask him it
generated a lot of interest and we
picked the most popular questions I will
not list all of them but one of the
biggest concerns among our Arab audience
is the future of Russian Arab ties when
you will no longer be the president of
Russia what will be the stance of your
successor on the issue it is not about
the name of the Russian president it is
about our national interests it is in
the interests of Russia and other
nations of the Russian Federation to
nurture relations with the Arab world
it's always appealed to Russia with its
enigma culture opportunities and
potential I have no doubt that Russia is
set to boost the pace of its interaction
with the Arab world in the years to come
I will try to be brief the Arab world is
following the recent developments in
both Russia and the Arab world as part
of the so-called Arab Spring the
situation is rapidly changing in Sudan
and Algeria Tunisia just had an election
do you see any positive signals do you
think the region is entering a new phase
that will culminate in a stable Middle
East can you snow clearly the region is
not in a state of stability we all
understand it we can see it with our own
eyes but all things pass I hope it will
be over one day it will not get better
quickly on its own if you just leave
things as they are without attempts to
improve the situation Russia will do all
it can to make sure things get back to
normal as soon as possible we do not
think that you can and
handle the situation from above as I
said we have many friends in the Arab
world it is time to get Syrian - the
Arab family to reinstate it in the Arab
League we will work hard to bring it
back to normal and to help our friends
however the pace the improvements will
ultimately depend on the people who are
responsible for the situation in their
country unconvinced stabilization is
inevitable and I wish it happens as soon
as possible